[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round 2 of the Fall
Classic here in st. Louis for decisive
in Group A with set to coos above and
Lenderman
all winning their games the trio joins
Alexi drove in the lead in Group B with
mate looming Ashwin resigned - ha ha
nice caboose e'en as the leaderboard
takes shape round 3 starts now
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
calm presents the 2nd annual fall chefs
classic hello chess fans and welcome
back to st. Louis it's day 3 round 3 of
the second annual fall chess classic my
name is Ben Simon join guys always by
international master and famed streamer
Eric Rosen Eric we have 10 games that
started the day we have 9 still in
progress that's right and it's raining
outside not the best weather to be
outdoors but very good chess weather
we're we're staying dry inside pumpkins
are staying fresh and I'm looking
forward to an exciting day of chess so
fresh let's take a look at the standings
so far in group a we don't have a clear
winner yet but after three the three
decisions yesterday we do have four
liters one and a half points at the top
and now let's take a look at the B group
and this is after two rounds and you can
see up until the start of today we did
have a clear winner in gabbu Xion the
2017 Armenian champion with Brandon
Jacobson in clear second now there have
been some slight changes there that
we'll talk about in just a little
because one game has ended but a lot of
fun so far Eric here in this tournament
let's take a look at the tournament
format this
is a round-robin event there are two
fields and the time control is 90
minutes for the first 40 moves there are
30 minutes added on each clock after
each player's 40th move and there is a
30 second increment from move number one
because of the increment both players
have to take notation from beginning
until the very end and it's also
important to note Erik that there is a
30 move draw rule in effect the players
cannot agree to a draw
before Black's thirtieth move which is
producing a lot of hard-fought games we
saw actually we didn't see yesterday but
after the broadcast ended there's a very
long marathon battle between Al Jean
Marie EBIT and Konrad Holt's which
lasted over five and a half hours so
it's possible we'll see some some more
marathon battles today fighting chess
that's the name of the game all right
let's take a look at the tournament
schedule our broadcast is abbreviated
you can follow these games online at us
chess champs calm every day at 1:00 p.m.
Central Time we will join you two and a
half hours after the opening bell at
3:30 p.m. each day and of course at last
day we're making room for some playoffs
starting a little bit early at 11 a.m.
Central okay we would encourage you to
enjoy to join us on social media across
all platforms we are streaming live on
YouTube and twitch and we are taking
questions and comments from our YouTube
chat so be civil and be intelligent and
we'll do our best
join the conversation online with
hashtag fall chess classic and I do want
to give a shout out to first twitch in
the chat already showing the the hammer
time emotes hammer is a very notorious
streamer and he is he has some fans in
the in the chat so far and there's good
reason he had a lot of fans that's right
there's a lot of strong players in this
event let's take a look at the pairings
for today in Group A we have alexei
gribov versus erik hansen daro spirits
versus young Luke Vega hammer var a
cobia vs. Lazaro bruise own Alex
Linderman vs. ray Robson
and Eric Archy matcha it's right Grand
Master Eureka Zubov against Grandmaster
Sethuraman two players who have won in
half out of two who are sharing the lead
so far and I do want to take a look at
their game and see what progress has
been made I want to go back and take a
look at the opening we saw a semi tirage
which is something you don't see too
much at the amateur level because black
very early in the game gives up the
center allowing light to have these two
very nice E&D pawns which is usually
something you want to achieve in the
opening from early on and it took me a
while to actually understand why this
opening is playable for black because it
seems like black is just giving away a
space advantage quite early but the
reasoning is that black has it's very
nice move pawn to e5 after Knight f3
ctek d4 seat 84 Bishop to b4 check what
this does is it forces a trade of minor
pieces and when a couple minor pieces
come off the board so early then the
space advantage for white isn't isn't so
strong as it would be if all the minor
pieces stand on the board now going
forward here both players I think we're
in a pretty reasonable preparation this
position has been played many times
before and then on move 14 the black
played a an incredibly rare move I was
looking at this earlier the main move
here is rook to CH which is played
hundreds of times before black shows
this very move Queen c7 which strike me
as a bit odd because usually in these
positions the Queen likes to go to e7
and thus gave white the opportunity to
play a simple move rook c1 to simply
target the Queen on the C file but kusa
Bob did not choose to go for this
instead he played Bishop to d3 which
allowed black this very nice center
break pawn e5 and going forward from
here Brooke a c1 the Queen was able to
transfer itself to d6 getting away from
the danger of the white rook after
Bishop b5 II take d4 d5 and Queen g6 we
see that black is beginning to organize
some King side attack the combination of
the Queen and the bishop glaring down
from
b7 this looks a bit scary for the white
side and we shouldn't note that this
night is currently hanging on d7 but if
white were to capture it then there
would be a bishop take f3 and this would
be a nice trade for black given that
Bach is keeping the initiative with with
these mating threats so I do see that a
few moves have been played since Queen
to g6 Knight h4 was played let me update
the game and take us to the current
position after after Knight h4 Queen g4
and now rook c4 so white is going after
this week pawn on d4 and after Knight
takes e5 rook takes d4 Queen h5 this
brings us to the current position where
all the central pawns have dissolved if
I'm counting correctly black is up a
pawn but seems like white is better
centralized here with these two rooks
nicely placed in the center and play
keeps developing Queen - wait a minute
Oh Bishop e2 is played Queen h6 Queen
take h6 and G take h6 and I believe this
is a current position we can take a look
at the time situation URI Cuza Boff
already under five minutes to make about
17 moves so he might be under pressure
but he does have cops a bit more
activity and now box pawn structure is a
bit damaged on the King side so I'm
expecting a long fight still to come you
notice you noted that since who was up a
pawn and then the Queen's came off the
board you usually you don't want to
trade when you're down material but do
you think that URI thought that a an
attack on the D file by black was
inevitable and that's why he traded off
Queens that's a good question I think I
think their reasoning for trading Queens
is simply to weaken the BOK pawn
structure we can see now that all of the
King side pawns are isolated ends
usually double H pawns are not the the
prettiest structure to have especially
later in the game and what this is going
to allow white to do is bring a Knight
to f5 or
so-called knife f5 where the light will
be targeting not only h6 but also it's
very juicy d6 square and I do like
White's compensation here for being down
upon and I think black will have some
some issues to solve but I think this is
a position where it's it's very
imbalanced on both sides still do have
chances well we'll have to keep an eye
on this game but in the meantime let's
shift our focus over to Group B let's
take a look at the pairings in Group B
today now these games all of them are in
progress except for one of them we'll
talk about that in just a moment we have
Chris u versus Sergei as a Rob Stevens
Erick vs. Akshat Chandra Ashwin Jha ROM
vs. Brandon Jacobson Danish Boros vs.
Konrad holt and our game of the day in
Group B yeah the tournament leader - ace
boo-boos Ian going up against Al Shawn
more indium body it had a very quick
game they finished in about an hour and
pieces just liquidated really quickly I
do want to take a look at the opening
though just to give viewers perhaps some
inspiration something to perhaps
consider to play against pawn d4 and
move on after Knight f6 c4 c6 9 f3 this
is a common position and normally from
the white perspective you would expect
to move like d5 just transposing into a
Slav standard Slav defense instead we
saw a move that I've never seen before
until today this move pawn to b5 have
you ever seen this before Ben no I have
it no this is it's very strange usually
want to look to to put your pawns in the
center but this attempts to do is trade
a winged pawn for a more centralized
pawn and usually in the opening the more
centralized pawns are of greater value
and Alshon decided to capture on b5 and
it was an interesting structure given
that black now has a very nice square
for the bishop on b7 to try and try and
pressurize the position with with this
fianchetto
and as play developed it seemed like
they
closed into a somewhat symmetrical
structure after Pawnee six-night BT to
d5 we can see this is already looking
quite symmetrical and they actually
transposed into what looks like an
exchange Slav we're after after several
more moves okay both players developed
and at some points pieces just started
coming off the board very rapidly around
move 14 Knight take b7 Queen take d7 and
the trades just continued and at some
point the position got incredibly dry
after more pieces came off the board and
it seemed like both players were we're
content with just drawing the game and
we can see here there is nothing much to
fight for now I know al Shan has been
recovering from some sickness especially
these couple starting rounds so I'm sure
he's happy two paths that have a
somewhat of a rest day today to recoup
and and go into the later rounds with
with more energy well and so now that we
have seen this game end in a draw no
player in this tournament it has a
perfect score anymore it's anyone's
tournament in either field really I know
we're still early on but what do you say
let's take a look at some of the other
games in this event I was glancing at
Akopian and burrs own in Group A and
there is if I'm looking at the current
position and there's a fork let's see
how we got there in a cobia and burrs
own yeah and there is a backstory to the
start of this game bruise own had some
issues with his cab from what I heard
and showed up about 20 to 25 minutes
late it's really close to the cutoff for
the people who don't know the
regulations for this event say that if
you are half hour late it's not just a
half hour taking off your clock you
forfeit that game and along with that
along with that provision if you are
late for the round period it says on the
website US chess champs calm that you
could be fined $500 now we don't know if
that fine will be applied to
burrs own in this case we understand it
was a cab issue I think so maybe not
directly his fault so maybe an exception
will be made really can't speak on that
but that is the rule right now so he
came very close to forfeiting this game
right and we can see at least a current
time situation he's still down on time
but nothing too bad and thankfully for
him he was able to arrive and they went
into a nimzo-indian and I'm a Kobe and
unleashed a move that has been trendy
especially lately by by the well-known
American player Fabiana Caruana Viviano
is playing this quite frequently at some
recent events over the summer with very
good success and we can see that okay
they went into what we have kind of a
catalan structure the Kevon being very
popular opening at high level play
keeping a lot of tension the bishop on
g2 not only a nice attacking piece that
exerts a lot of pressure in the center
of it also can keep the White King quite
safe I do want to zoom forward and take
a look at how a Cobian developed in the
middle game night h3 is not a move that
you see every day especially in Queens
pawn openings but the purpose of this
moves keep the bishop not not obstructed
and keep the pressure on d5 and as we'll
see very soon a Cobian went for Knight
f4 again applying a lot of pressure and
then eventually went for F 3 e 4 so
let's see how this does play out after a
5 9 F for c6 castling 96 and f3 it's a
somewhat unusual setup to put the pawn
on f3
but clearly a KO being wants to break
down the center with Pawnee 4 and he did
just that after E 4 D take E 4 FK key
for we can see these two very nice
Center pawns and unlike the game I was
showing earlier between coos above and
Sapphira man this position features
white having two Center clones with all
the minor pieces still on the board and
that that usually leads some more
favorable advantage for the white side
given that black is very Krantz
especially with the minor pieces they
don't have too many squares to access
now we do see a an attempt to break down
the center in this position with pawn to
c5 trying to remove the pond potentially
activates the black bishop but Akopian
just keeps pushing pawn on e5 kicking
the Knights back to g7 and then Bishop
e3 I really like the opening by a Kobe
and everything seems very purposeful and
it seems like he's growing his advantage
maybe taking taking full advantage of
the fact that that his opponent was not
at the game on time I do on the zoom
forward here because many more moves
have been played some trades did take
place in the center but it seems like a
Cobian is keeping a nice pole in the
position still has more space the
bishops do get traded on in the center
actually and in this moment we do see a
an interesting tactic rook takes e5
taking advantage of the fact that after
rook takes e5 there is Bishop to e3 and
it was like this is the fork yeah it's
uh not winning material for black but
but simply trading and okay many more
moves have been played let me update the
position after Bishop e3 King g2 Bishop
takes e5 we see some some further
tactics actually in this position I
would encourage the viewers to to think
for a moment and try and find the pawn
winning move for white in this position
any ideas Ben so he just White's move
here White's a move and I believe
Akopian did manage to win a pawn with a
nice it's discovered attack tactic
you should keep in mind f7 is a very
juicy target yeah this I mean I'm
looking at I was just trying to
calculate through and it does require a
calculation I'll go ahead and show the
first move here this should take f7 not
only attacking a king but also
unleashing the Queen along the D file
and we should keep in mind that this
rook is now overworked the rook is is
wanting to defend the Queen but also
wanting to take the bishop it can't get
away with taking the bishop after a
bishop take f7 this force is blocked to
play King h8 and after a queen take d8
rook takes Yeats a Cobian is now up a
clean pawn it seemed like this
combination is perhaps calculated way in
advance when all of these trades and
enforcing moves took place and now we
should note there are obstacle our
bishops which do give blacks some
potential drawing chances but I do like
a Cobian in this position just being up
a clean pawn
especially with a 6 on the horizon this
a pawn is going to be a constant
nuisance for black to deal with and
especially with the time advantage - I
do like a Kobe's chances to win this
position have you ever shown up to a
tournament significantly late doesn't
have to be your fault
I just say I will admit that it has
happened to me it actually happened in a
really important game I was playing in
the 2015 phileo pin' I had thought the
round started at I think 1030 but it
started at 10 and I was preparing for
the game around 10:00 10:15 now I got a
call from one of my students parents
saying why I wasn't at the board and it
was a really important game because if I
won the game
I would clinch my final I am norm I was
20 minutes late for the game thankfully
there was no sort of forfeiture rule if
I showed up late and I actually
unleashed some nice opening preparation
it worked out we're preparing for the
game really helped I blitzed out my
opening preparation I moved 15 I had
equalized on time and actually won the
game with the black pieces and clinched
the norm so I can't say that I've had a
bad experience showing up late but that
was
one time I was the ignorance for the
around schedule so it is important for
anyone playing in any sort of events
that you make sure what time the game
starts because you don't want to make
any embarrassing miss scheduling
especially around here you know
sometimes around start day to day
different times right yeah that's a very
important thing to do I do have to say
that Danish boorish and Conrad Holt have
drawn their game over in Group B that is
the second game in Group B to finish I
don't know if you want to take a look at
that I know we have a lot of action
going on we'll take a quick glance I see
a very symmetrical King pawn ending
position we saw a king pond ending I
believe in the first round between
ostrich on remand Conrad Holtz where
Austin was able to grind down than the
King pawn ending because Conrad had some
damage palm structure but we can see
this was just a very clear draw seemed
like the position was relatively equal
even going back a few moves a lot of
things got traded this is actually a
really interesting sequence let me go
back maybe two to this moment Bishop e5
it's not taking a look at this game
earlier Bishop e5 looks like it's pretty
enticing tactic skewering the rook and
the Queen however a black does have this
pin along the C file so light was not
ending up winning material and after
Bishop d6 a really interesting idea that
Dennis played here allowing black to
capture the Queen on c2 after rook takes
c2 rook takes see two black currently
has a queen for a night and a rook but
White has the unstoppable threats of
rook c8 and black actually has to be a
bit careful here not to allow work seats
and go down material I believe the only
move for black which was played this
Queen take d6 rook see a check
forcing Queen f8 and this is what led us
into very Josh and game looks like they
played until exactly move 30 and then
agreed on a draw in this position
okay so there's still plenty of action
left one thing we didn't look at at the
top of the show is what's on the line in
this event and we're talking about five
hundred dollar penalty perhaps being
lobbied toward one of the players that
will be offset if applied by the prize
fund let's take a look at what's on the
line in Group A $6,000 first prize going
all the way down the last full response
will get at least one thousand so no
one's going home empty-handed and in
Group B $14,000 total prize fund going
all the way down to the last two spots
getting $500 so if you finish it last
and you're late you're going home with
nothing in theory so best of luck to
these guys and we hope we can get some
reliable transportation of course yeah
sometimes it depends on whether - I know
that the weather can slow things down
say sometimes you have to check the
forecast ahead of time right right right
now one of the nice guys in chess Ashwin
Jha ROM he's playing over in Group B
with Brandon Jacobson who is looking for
norms in this event let's take a look at
what's going on here
yeah we see uh currently see a very
complex position Ashwin is quite low on
time I do want to go back and take a
look at the opening this was one of the
more unusual openings of the rounds
where Ashwin is is a very classical d4
player and okay here we see a ready
opening where black eventually does play
or white eventually does play upon d4
and now black decided to employ the
double fianchetto Jeff I'm not mistaken
I believe this was called the Hydra
system and I believe game yeah have you
have you seen this before I mean I've
tried it I didn't know that I had a name
I believe this if I'm not mistaken it
might be Vitaly Nemer who is given given
some lectures on this before where yes
the the setup of the the black bishops
you do have some purpose trying to
pierce through the center the issue for
black is that white gained space very
early and after black households in this
position Ashwin played a very ambitious
move on g5 just simply trying to shut
out the
Bishop on b7 and then Jacobsen played a
very strange move here Knight to e4
perhaps going against some opening
principles moving the same piece twice
when he's not fully developed and the
night seems quite loose on e4 and after
Knight f2 d2
the Black Knight retreated to d6 and
this just seems like a very awkward
setup for lack putting the knight in
front of from the center pawns and it's
very odd that none of the center pawns
for for black have moved thus far don't
see this too often in any opening where
only the the G and E pawns have moved
going forward here efore is played and
the position just seemed really
attractive for for Oswin
seemed like he was able to keep the
space advantage at least keep the center
pawns and complete development going
forward here we do see that Jacobsen is
trying to break down white structure
this reminds me a little bit of the
Cobian game with this Bishop pawn
battery trying to break down the pawn
and strong pawn Center not Ashwin was
was even more ambitious here rather than
perhaps liquidating on c6 he advances
further in the center pawn to e5 kicking
away the night from d6 and light lands
on c4 and then offstring continues to
dominate the senator queen d4 on this is
such a basic opening principle in chess
where you want to control the center
from early on it seems like Ashwin is
doing just SATs with just a very
beautiful setup with all the pieces and
box pieces seem a bit that this
coordinated in this position now there
were some trades that took place on d5
after Knight takes e5 Bishop to 85 Queen
take d5 rook c8 is played but white is
maintaining the pressure here at Bishop
g5 Queen c7 and rook e 2 c1 brings us to
the current position and it seems like a
very nasty pin for black to deal with
here I mean the immediate threat just
appears to be b3 and I'm not sure how
black is going
to escape this given that the Queen on
c7 is tied down to defending the Knights
on c4 so it seems a bit problematic for
for Brandon now he does have a time
advantage but it seems like both players
are gonna be getting pretty low on time
with still many moves to make until
extra time is added so this is the
current position right now I will update
one more time but yes is the current
position after rook ec1 we see both
players sitting at the board there
Brandon seems to be very focused
Austrian leaning back always nice when
you see your opponent is uh gots a bit
stressed out and you can lean back and
just sort of relax but Ashwin has to be
careful not to get too relaxed as we do
want to remember what happened yesterday
with him his game against kuboos Ian
never got to relax when your position
seems solid yeah I mean is it all doom
and gloom though for Jacobsen right here
because if it's black to play I mean
can't the Queen retreat - like d8 and
then on the next move you just move the
knight well we have to be careful Bishop
is ultra long d8 if the Queen retreats
to b8 the knight would drop so the Queen
asked to find the square where it's not
where it's still defending the Knights
now one move that comes to mind is
something like Queen c6 to attempt to
remove the Queen from d5 but seems like
white still has some very nice pressure
here
not sure if white would want to go for
the Queen trade or perhaps keep keep the
Queen's on the board we could imagine
that White has some initiative that
Queen takes c6 rook takes c6 and I'm
envisioning either some discovered
attack with some idea of 94 or even some
backward attacking move like Bishop f1
given that the Knights are aligned on
this this diagonal and if we imagine
Bishop f1 and black might have to play
b5 and then white has a very principled
move pawn to a4 and seems like in many
lines black will be under pressure and
seems like this is exactly what Ashley
wants
just a number of possibilities to
consider and when black is under
pressure like this it can really drain
down the time I do like White's chances
in in this position okay well maybe it's
more doom and gloom than I thought one
of the games in group a between two
players who are winless thus far daro
and the hammer it's it looks like Black
has a pretty significant advantage here
let's take a look at this game in Group
A in between daro and the hammer yeah
this is not a game I was taking a look
at earlier we should point out the the
time disparity white having a just over
a minute left to make over 20 moves I'm
very curious to take a look at the
opening I was not taking a look too
closely at this game earlier they did go
into a Spanish variation with black
playing this very early d5 but sometimes
when your opponent attempts to open up
the center early and with the Kings
still uncle it makes sense to try and
allow the center to just open up and we
see this is exactly what white does pawn
to d4 is complete confusion in the
center with so many different possible
captures pawn to e4 played leaving the
bishop attacked the counter attacking
the knight on f3 and after Knight to e5
Knight takes e5 the bishop has taken
Queen e7 is played and now we see a an
interesting tactic by white Bishop takes
e4 it looks like the bishop is simply
undefended here but the point is after
Knight takes e4 again I would encourage
the viewers to find that the tactical
resource that white has in this position
I'll give a small clue here that this
Knight is undefended and so is a rook
and the idea is how white can double
attack in this position
me thinking again I was thinking rookie
one yeah rookie one seems like one of
the most natural moves to just pressure
the the e-file but that's not what white
played white played the oh nice
geometric move Queen to d5 when you
place a queen in the center it has so
much potential to attack so many
different targets in this case white is
guaranteed to win one of these pieces
black chose to save the Knights and give
up the rook and this actually reminds me
of a game yesterday between Ray Robson
and Eureka Zubov Ray intentionally
sacrificed her rook in the corner
allowing the Queens to take the rook but
then the Queen got stuck and then it was
a battle to to see if there was enough
compensation for being down the exchange
now white is up the exchange here but
the Queen was a bit out of play and
let's go forward here because we see
black does get some nice compensation
the night landing on d3 very nice in the
heart of White's territory the Knights
are what we call superfluous these are
Knights that defend each other they
coordinate very well in this case and
seems like black was able to get some
significant compensation I do like this
move pawn to c5 perhaps just going for
upon c4 to reinforce the knight on d3
after b4 we see this move Queen to d7
which I'm trying to figure out what the
purpose of this is it's possible that
the queen is eyeing this this g4 square
maybe even planning something like the
ship to b7 combined with Queen to d5
after white plays Queen to e4 black
continues the pressure pawn to f5 very
nice move with tempo attacking the Queen
and then after Queen h4 black just keeps
pushing pawn f4 and now it's a the
question to the bishop seems very
uncomfortable for whites given that okay
the pawn is well supported the bishops
attacks and now we see Knight to e4
which
is a bit strange I was expecting this
Bishop takes e5 move to be played
attempting to save the bishop but now
I'm realizing that this would just
probably lose material after Knight
takes e5 B takes e5 and Queen take t2
and black would have it be having two
minor pieces for a rook in in this case
seemingly a very nice advantage for
black so it seemed like white was
actually forced to lose a piece here
given that the bishop is essentially
trapped that's probably why it why chose
ninety four and now hammer is thinking
in this position making use of his time
advantage this is one of the things when
you're up on time your points so a long
time you'll have these perhaps moments
where you can can just sit and relax and
and calculate while the opponent will be
forced to play on pure intuition it's
best to think about your move it's even
better to think on your opponent's time
though that is true it's very true and I
think one more move has been played we
see Queen d5 on the board just seems
like a complete mess in the center like
look at this configuration for lack the
queen of knights and now there is
there's a tax on both the the knight on
e4 and the bishop on e3 always nice when
when there's multiple targets or at
least multiple pieces hanging in this
case we're now White has to perhaps
figure out which piece can be saved and
I like box set up here given that
there's ideas of Bishop e7 on the
horizon with an additional target on g2
and even though white is temporarily
still up the exchange I really like
blacks chances with the current position
and the time situation is hammered just
winning he could be I mean I don't have
access to the engine evaluation but I
really like his chances I think the time
situation says it all we see that daro
is from the brink of flagging I see he
just played a move
I'm quite sure what he played in props
capturing on c5 not sure if we can zoom
in there and and see camera is zooming
in do you see a white piece on c5 looks
like Bishop takes e5 was played and now
it's a question to black I mean the
knight is hanging on e4 but the rook is
under attack on f8 and when I look at
the position like this I would be very
much inclined to start calculating these
lines with Queen techie for Bishop take
f8 and then Bishop e7 with just a
seemingly monstrous attack against this
pawn on g2 looks like the only move for
whites to hold on would be something
like f3 but then after Queen e3 check
the King would be forced to h1 and not
sure if this is working out actually in
blacks favor 9f2 looks deadly right the
problem is white is controlling f2 twice
you would really like to achieve this
has some other meaning idea it might
take some additional work I was thinking
that Bach would like to take on f8 here
and then have a very strange material
imbalance where Locke would have three
minor pieces for a rook and r2 Ruxin
upon something you don't see every day I
think the problem here is white would
have Queen d8 forcing king f7 and then
Queen c7 winning back some material not
sure if black is getting so much in this
line so if we go back to the current
position hammer is thinking here perhaps
pondering whether to take on e4 or I
mean we might just see a simple rook
move maybe something like rook to e8 or
up d8 to just keep the keep the pressure
and in a situation like this sometimes
you you do want to keep the pressure to
give your opponent options and just
perhaps provoke a mistake when they're
so low on time we do have another result
our first result of the day in Group A
as Yuri who's above and cerumen
have gone to a draw and so both players
are now sitting still at the top with
two points apiece and is this something
you want to take a look at or shall we
you could keep moving
it seems like a very dry position I
think okay the position was a bit lively
earlier I was thinking it was imbalanced
enough for both players to continue
fighting but it seems like okay the full
fire is just steered towards a very dry
ending where black did have the extra
pawn for a little bit but white had
activity so what black decided to do was
give back the pawn with this move b5 and
and as the rooks came off the board this
is just a drawing
rook ending so not much to look at but
perhaps there's some some other more
interesting games to to check out yes
let's take a look at Alexei Draya versus
Erik Hansen also in Group A this is an
interesting game rook and Knight versus
rook and Bishop and pawns on the board
yeah certainly very imbalanced
I'm counting material here and we do see
that dray of is up a pawn seemingly a
very nice position for white and not the
best situation for the chess brah
Eric looks a bit uncomfortable they're
fidgeting around it's at a Red Bull de I
see on his I saw him drinking coke
yesterday early in the game which is
normally I don't as something I don't
recommend for students to do where you
you have like a very large sugar intake
early on it can cause you to crash
later on in the game I usually prefer to
drink tea or or juice to keep kind of a
constant flow of energy but decoration
yeah it's decoration yeah potential
sponsorship perhaps he's got that
Nakamura deal going you know it's
possible maybe but okay if we take a
look at the current position g5 was a
most recent move actually one more move
has been played rook to d3 and now we
see Hanson
sneaking here can't be too happy though
given that mean White has everything
defended and this might is just quite
powerful in the center I think white
it's probably ready to play e4
quite soon to to support the knight even
further now this isn't a pretty open
position where typically in the these
endgame positions Knights are usually a
bit worse and bishops but this line is
just very impressive and it seems like
this Bishop is just not really doing too
much on a7 so this is a case where the
night is a bit superior to the bishop
and I would imagine that Draves
long-term plan is to someday create a
passed pawn on the Queen side whether it
be to eventually play I'll move like
before to trade off the pawns or maybe
even to go after this this a five pawn
which is a potential weakness I'm
envisioning some idea like efore
followed by 93 followed by room to d5
and maybe even later play Knight c4 it
the flight can continue to perhaps
reposition the pieces and attack blacks
weaknesses looks pretty difficult to
defend for for black this game you think
this game is one that's gonna be going
on for a while but you definitely give
Draya the advantage yeah I mean I don't
expect Hansen to give up so easily I
know he's a fighter but I would expect
Dre of two to convert I mean Draya is a
very very formidable formidable player
very very strong in converting
converting better positions and I've
seen many of his games and when he gets
to advantage he he likes to get that
grip on the opponent so I would be I
would be surprised if Eric can can hold
on for a draw from this position also in
Group A we haven't taken a look at
Alexander Lindemann versus Ray Robson as
of yet and there's still a lot of
material on the board
Ray has down to two minutes left the
players have ten more moves about maybe
nine until they make time control and
yeah we should note this is an
interesting matchup you
Olympiad coach versus aus Olympia team
member and you see ray is wearing the
u.s. Olympia jacket jacket that I saw
many pictures of during Olympia in
Batumi just a few weeks ago but it was
definitely some spirit there he's
wearing it every day I'm sure he's not
gonna stop you know I see lunderman
wearing one of the st. Louis Chess Club
green jackets which is quite appropriate
for the weather with a hood on apparel
here yeah we do yeah it's 2018 u.s.
championship rain jacket yeah yeah
there's some nice nice insulation but
yeah if we take a look at the current
situation I know ray is somewhat
notorious for getting low on time and in
this game he's living up to expectations
two minutes left
to make 10 more moves looks like one
more move has been played by lunderman
rook to h4 and I like this position for
white for many reasons I mean there's
there's some imbalances here but White
has a bishop pair two bishops against
two knights I really can't complain with
that we see this double-team caddo setup
and what this allows is it allows white
at any points play a move like Bishop
take nights and when white is able to
perhaps be the one to initiate trades
this will allow white to perhaps dictate
what direction the game will go towards
we see one more move from Ray Knight to
e5 and now okay both Knights could
potentially be taken we should note that
White's queen is currently under attack
I would expect the White Queen to
retreat in this position I think what
Lenderman wants to do is just leave all
the tension and try and create a tense
position where Ray could go wrong I
wouldn't be surprised if we see a move
perhaps like Queen to e2 another thing
we should note is that black has some
somewhat damaged bone structure somewhat
ugly pawns on the clean side double
isolated pawns also an isolated pawn
d 5 and what this allows Wyatt is to
potentially have a very nice square for
the bishop on d4 to blockade the d5 pawn
potentially very soon well we might see
a move like this ship to d4 where the
pawn on d5 is completely pocketed and
then blacks pieces won't necessarily be
able to activate further so I do like
Lenderman chances in in this game very
nice we've been in group a for a while
so let's happen skip over to group B
Chris you versus Sergei as a robb
we have not seen this game yet the
players are on move number 35 and
they're both very equal in time this is
an interesting position while I'm going
on here Chris you one of the the
youngest player in in the whole event
only what is he 11 12 years old he is
well either 11 or 12 years old yeah born
in 2006 that's all I have is the birth
home but he's world number 2 for every
player under 12
so he's higher rated than me yes I I
beat him in a protest League game a
couple years ago but I feel like that
might be the last time I'll ever get a
chance to take him down in there we know
he hasn't had the best start in in this
event but he is very much a fighting
player and we see another imbalance I
gave him another scenario where it is
Bishop versus night let's go back just a
few moves see how this position unfolded
we do you see that as RF have some very
nice pressure on the C file and right
off the bat I I do prefer blacks
position given that the seat c3 pawn
it's just a backward isolated pawn it's
kind of a nuisance to defend both rights
both of whites rooks
are quite passive in this position we
see g3 played and black is now slowly
improving with King f8 rook to d3 and we
should note that this d5 pawn is also a
weakness and after keen e7 Christopher
grabs his pawn
on d5 and now we might see a lot of a
lot of liquidation I can imagine that's
if night 85 is played rooked 85 black
will win back the pawn on c3 and at
first glance you would have to prefer
black I mean the rooks are a lot more
coordinated and it seems like black is
kind of crashing through given that a3
and g3 are now additional targets to
exploit but I do see a nice possibility
here for whites if this position does
occur I would expect rook to d3 just
trying to neutralize the third-ranked
not allow any of the pawns to become too
weak and just trying hold hold the
grounds and then it's a decision for
black whether to trade a pair of rooks
or keep both Brooks on the board I would
probably expect to move like rook to c1
forcing the King to move up and then
perhaps RIPTA rook 7 to c2 and we see
that blacks rooks are a lot more active
than whites rooks and it might be that
black isn't necessarily going for
materials so soon Locke is just trying
to activate the rooks and not sure if
this is big enough advantage so in the
game but certainly an advantage
nonetheless for for black and in this
position and we actually do see I was
predicting the future there this is a
current position rook to d3 on the board
and I am expecting let's say I was
expecting rook to c1 we see as our of
his plate rook to c2 which is perhaps an
even stronger move simply cutting the
King off and maybe even pondering the
idea of potentially later rookie to with
mating ideas on the back rank I really
like this move rook c2 another example
of a pig on the second and this is gonna
be quite annoying for a white because
there's no immediate way to neutralize
one defensive IC idea that I see here
for why it is to play rook f3 attempting
to go for rook f2 and then
and then utilize before black and double
up so maybe there's still some some
chances for light to try and neutralize
Eric I don't mean to interrupt but yeah
although I will in group hey hammer has
trapped Darrow's Queen and it looks like
it looks like we are about to see the
end of this game if they didn't shake
already we if you go back a move
actually uh you'll see that daro had to
capture with his jeep on it but then
another night lands in and I think the
Queen is trapped this seems like a dream
come true for a hammer I want to go back
to where we last left off after a bishop
take c5 and just just admire that
initiative that black was able to employ
in this position Knight g6 Queen g5 and
then rook f5 seems like every move from
lack is now either a threat or capture
Bach wins tonights on e4 Bishop d4 rook
goes back to f8 this is a backwards
attacking move it unleashes a bishop
targeting the White Queen and it's over
and when we see a handshake yeah very
nice game from hammer the his first win
right so I'm determined it is yes it is
this first one yeah it lost the first
day and a draw yesterday
we should probably get him in here if we
can that would be great I know he has a
good number of fans in the twitch chat
we can see I'm seeing some more of
Hammer emotes from past pawn 99 in the
twitch chat and of course from vert
which to some Norway flags so certainly
a fan base that we can see so it would
be great to interview him today yeah
we'll probably get him in here okay so
that is the first decision to go in
someone's full favour in Group A now can
we just admire the ending to this yes
please yes surely because literally
every single move for like the last I
think 5 to 10 moves of this game was
just a monstrous threats and ok Queen h3
on
a move by hammer knife f4 going off for
the Queen after a gta4 knife again
captures on f4 and thus Queen is trapped
now it looks like the Queen has perhaps
a few safe squares to move to given that
all of these squares are undefended or
uncovered by by black but all of these
squares run into just a devastating
Knight to e2 and it's either going to be
a fork or a discovered attack so for
example Queen G 492 lat is winning the
Queen if Queen G 392 black is a kind of
winning the Queen and this is what we
call hammer time
it's just putting the hammer down and
very nice victory for for the Norwegian
yes the man with the greatest name in
chess okay so while we are waiting on a
potential interview what game have we
not seen yet I think that we've taken a
look at everything that was lopsided
here guess we can jump back to the
Cobian game because he is trying to
maximize his advantage and just going
back a few moves after Queens were
traded we left off around here he played
rook to c1 and then we see Brooks to d2
check and Kobe to move debating where to
move his king if the King moves that's
to h3 looks like the safest Square then
there's some some issues for black on
the back rink and I'm not entirely sure
how black is solving this given that if
the bishop moves anywhere then rook c8
is coming and if we move like b6 is
plain and simply b4
trying to discourage the bishop or drive
the bishop away from c5 if I take D for
a take before it should take before rook
c8 would be game over so I'm not
entirely sure unless I'm missing
something I'm not sure what black is
going to do after King h3 you only see
one thing I do see it looks very
depressing for black but it might be
necessary is to play Bishop to f8 we're
treating all the way making sure that
rook c8 isn't an immediate check and
then to play g6 and after rook take f8
there's King g7 with the fork but this
looks very preferable for whites
I'm sure white would be happy to give
back the piece after something like rook
b8 and then still have some advantage in
the resulting rook endgame maybe there's
something better for for white but we
have hammer outside the studio so we're
gonna get him in here in just a moment
but yeah let's continue looking at this
game in the interim yeah I'm the curious
Maya Cobian is thinking here let me just
update the board he's probably debating
what is he debating because if he Moses
came to f3 or f1 then there's rook after
to check and that would be picking up
the bishop Carly doesn't want to go into
that so he's probably debating whether
to play King h3 or King h1 but both
players not quite in time trouble they
still have some time left to try and
figure things out so let's move on to a
different game and see what is going on
in in the chest bras game a few more
moves have been played we see the last
move b4 which is an idea that I was
talking about earlier given that White's
does want to create a passed pawn on the
Queen side and now we can imagine that
white either wants to play d5 or capture
on e5
I would probably expect black to capture
on
for in this position and after an I take
before white is having the the past a
pond there would be ideas of rook d7
check also knight Knight to c6 check
some nice forking possibilities but we
will keep an eye on this game and take a
look at how it develops but in the
meantime I do want to welcome to the
studio unit Ludwig hammer
congratulations on your first win of the
events thank you so let me ask you what
was the preparation going into this game
it seemed like just a very beautiful
victory was very impressed with the
finish of the game it just seemed like a
complete tactical massacre that white
had to undergo take us through the the
beginning of the game how much of this
was opening preparation well I played an
opening I have never played before
thinking that after having a lost
position in 12 moves with white two
games in a row it couldn't possibly get
worse and so I played this Bishop c5 I
was inspired by a game I so last night I
was browsing the chess publishing
website and I noticed this idea and I
crime Nika Spock had played it in
Dortmund against Napoleon she and I
thought well if Kramnik place it then he
probably researched it really thoroughly
and so I thought okay I can play this
but I didn't actually do the job I just
I checked some of the main lines and I
assumed that
well since kramnik did it it's probably
okay but already here after b5 Bishop b3
was the move in the Nepali action game
so Bishop c2 is is much more
enterprising because it kind of forces
black to to stake a claim to the center
with d5 and now when he played d4 I was
already out of book which is kind of
embarrassing but
the thing is that I there are some crazy
lines starting with a four instead of d4
there's a four take some efore take some
b5 take some f3 queen takes f 3e for
Bishop takes 95 Queen e2 castles and now
if you take the vert the 93 it's very
annoying well because it kind of limits
all White's pieces so instead instead of
Bishop takes a a you go d4 and now
Bishop g4 Queen c2 takes on e4 takes
back and this has been played in four
games or it or something wow that's
great it's just I mean it's it goes
beyond this because Knight f3 is the
next move takes Bishop h3 takes them on
c5 takes on on f1 takes back between d1
check
Queen e1 to protect the bishop and then
Queen takes f3 Bishop e3 a takes b5 and
I mean still another test so you were
looking at all of this last night um
well I mean I wasn't really looking at
it I was just checking the games that
had been played in this and honestly I
don't think blacks position here is that
good I think this might I mean from what
I could figure out this position might
very well just be good for white but
it's I mean I'm coming into the game
surprising my opponent I made sure that
he doesn't play this with the black
piece early so I thought it's a
worthwhile risk but the problem then
being that when he played d4 reverting
to the game I didn't really know what
was going on I knew that this was one of
the
the main lines but I couldn't remember
after what I play it takes an e for it
takes text aches here I couldn't
remember what to do I wanted to exchange
the Queens but Queen takes repete Bishop
g4 and I started getting concerned about
f3 and I couldn't figure it out and and
and so I decided okay let's try to keep
the Queens instead but I immediately
regretted it because I started to
realize that after Bishop g5 and the 92
and white just gets a lot of pressure on
the pawn on e4 so I was pretty
pessimistic but he was taking a lot of
time to think and then he unleashed
Bishop takes e4 was this a move your
anticipate I had not seen it at all so
having had that bad start were the first
two games I got a very defeatist
attitude and I just thought oh my god
how could I not see this move what is
going on I'm getting crushed again this
tournament is terrible and when all
those thoughts but with hindsight this
was just a bad move but but also after
takes Queen d5 I mean I didn't have to
play as aggressively as I did and I
didn't even have to sacrifice the
exchange
what I realized afterwards was that even
Brooke be a queen takes Bishop e7 Queen
III and now castles I think okay I'm not
better
probably well the thing is I could be
better if he doesn't get rid of the
Queen's he yeah he's struggling to
develop his queen side so I kind of
think like he has to go f4 and get the
Queen song but then Knight g6
takes takes I have a beautiful diagonal
I have the square on f5 I can get my
rooks into the game
way quicker than him I mean III during
the game I regretted sacrificing the
exchange because I started realizing
that this is tremendous compensation for
a pawn but I got to check the computer
outside here and and the computer says I
played it like a genius really
I was wondering if it was some sort of
like deep opening preparation with
sacking the exchange because amount of
counter play you got is maybe what we
call accidental compensation where
didn't see a bishop take you for coming
but you just had so many resources yeah
afterwards yeah so castles so you do you
think his first a key mistake was Bishop
to g4 going into the squeen d5 line oh
for sure mm-hmm
well the computer told me so I see okay
yeah we're not using computer analysis
here so so to make conclusions yeah but
here I've really thought he should have
gone Bishop d4 instead make you - yeah
Bishop d4 and then that my problem is
that c5 Bishop takes e5 Bishop d7 this
is what I wanted to play but
unfortunately he
so I wasn't actually sure how to respond
to vision t4 mm-hm
yeah it's it's a cool position because I
mean why cos a queen exchanged down in a
reasonably symmetrical position you
wouldn't think that white isn't this
much trouble but after 90 to c5 it's
very difficult for him to find any moves
basically if he that his problem is
always that if he retreats the Queen
well now it's even too late but if he
does something like Queenie for he's
always getting hit by F 5 F 4 and then
the attack just becomes so dangerous so
when I point c5 I thought he had to play
P form which is what he did and I was so
happy with this move Queen t7 I think
this is fantastic
yeah it looks like a very kind of subtle
quiet move yeah well basically I'm
threatening knight c6 mm and it's it's a
threat that's very difficult for him to
face and also if I'm preventing Bishop
takes c5 because if Bishop takes e5
Dinah's very true
this should be pretty good for me and so
yeah I mean here he started he he was
down to just one minute for 20-something
and this is a great situation situation
to be in when you have so much pressure
and that's a long time it's connected
he's spending so much time because he is
that's very much pressure and he
couldn't find a good move he played
Queenie for I started pushing my pond
getting getting that one involved even
winning the piece back so in addition to
having a dominating position now I'm not
even material down and after 94 I the
whole game has been surrounded being
been about the the White Queen and
whether black can capture it so 25 I'm
not taking the bishop I want I want more
and now if Knight takes e5 Knight g6
attracts the Queen wow that's incredible
yeah peanuts no squares so so well he
had to play Bishop takes and once again
96 rook a5 the queen is in trouble I
think it's fair to say and now it's time
to take back the piece and I'm still
controlling his rooks this night on t3
is doing a fantastic job of making sure
that he he never gets any sort of
counter play with what is the the only
thing that the only good thing about his
position is the ropes but they can't get
involved and after Bishop d4 it's all
about just getting some attack to the
king
yeah I was very impressed with the
finale to this game seems like every
move was just a very strong threat and
the Queen was just sort of like a
punching bag it's running all over the
place here I could be fine but I really
like the aesthetic of just going for the
checkmate and also trapping the Queen
yeah yeah very very beautiful finish and
one of the probably the one of the most
fiery games of the tournament so far
maybe not the most intentional sacrifice
but definitely worked out in your favor
let me ask you how do you cope with
perhaps a slow start not not the best
performance in the first two games how
do you sort of rebound in and shift the
momentum well I I have a special method
of self pity but I I think there's no
easy answer to it a friend of mine is
say it's also a sports person and and
was kind of saying you shouldn't be
saying this stuff you're putting
yourself down you got a girl you're an
athlete you're a competitor you're
supposed to kind of strike back but but
I I kind of I would I'm unhappy with my
play but more I'm unhappy about my
tension if that makes sense
I don't think that my attitude after the
game can kind of change the fact that
I'm playing poorly because so my main
problem is not that I'm having a bad
result it's that I'm playing poorly and
I don't think this game was a fix
because I did not see there's so many
things I didn't see especially this
Bishop takes e4 yes it wasn't good but I
should still be aware of it with true so
so I but at the end of the day points is
what matters now I'm back on 50% I
this was just a huge game winning with
the black pieces against a strong
opponent in this fashion I'm ready for
the next round very nice night I do have
one more question because you are a
pretty notorious streamer on chess calm
these days and I saw you playing in
arena Kings tournament just a couple
days ago I believe after the first round
of the tournament do you plan to keep
streaming during this event maybe to
blow off some steam no well but
basically I considered doing some arena
king tournaments but those clash with
the tournament here that's true all
right so so I I think I did my my last
streaming from from from st. Louis sure
and you do have a very clear fan base
we're taking a look at the twitch chat
here and there there have been the
hammer emotes across across the
broadcast anything to say to your fans
well thank you for the support and I
hope I can get another game like this
but this one was this one was special
very nice well I will let you go and
congratulations again and best of luck
in later rounds we're gonna take a quick
commercial break and we will be back
with more coverage from the 2018 fall
chess classic
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premiere gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chest 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
be surprised and welcome back to st.
Louis it is day three of the 2018 fall
chess classic I'm Ben Simon along with
international master Eric Rosen and
during our interview we had a result in
Group B Stephen Zurich and action
Chandra have drawn their game but we
want to turn our attention over to Group
A it's var a cobia and Lazaro Brasil
let's take a look at what's happening
over in Group A it's true and we were
taking a look at this game earlier where
a coking was thinking after a rook to d2
check he did play King to h3 and razón
played really the only resource in this
position Bishop to f8 and after rook to
CH I was talking about this earlier
where I would probably expect to move
like g6 to prepare King g7 brew zone
played the more aggressive pawn to g5
and now it is a Cobian to move he is
able to capture the bishop but then he
would lose it right back after King g7
so the question becomes does white have
a way to really maximize advantage in
this position a Cobian is up upon but
but ok the black rook is active there is
a threat of rook take b2 perhaps coming
soon
there are also ideas of perhaps
targeting this King on on h3 as this
pawn has taken away some Square from
from the light King now of course a pawn
like h5 would like to be played but
probably runs into Bishop to h5 so it is
a question how does white proceed in
this position do you take the bishop
do you play something props like King g4
and the players players are still pretty
far away from making move 40 they're on
just completed move 29 so both players
below 5 minutes and I would expect some
some paste to increase over the next 10
moves yeah you would think so I mean
what we have now is a blitz game with a
30-second increments
and I guess it's not Blitzstein
equipment now I do want to switch to a
game in Group B which really caught my
eye has liquidated a ton between ash and
Jayram and brandon jacobson last time we
looked at this game it was some complex
middle game now we're deep into the
endgame White has lost all of the pawns
on the board we have a material
imbalance of night for three pawns with
Brooksville on the board and this is a
type of position it should just be a
theoretical draw but Ashwin having the
night will probably be the one playing
for the win and it's a matter of okay
keeping the black King cut off on the
seventh rank and trying to organize both
the Knights and the White King so
perhaps later come in for some mating
ideas but even the fact did not have any
of the pawns on the board rook versus
rook and Knight is usually a pretty easy
draw at the highest levels so this is
another draw draw number four would
expect a draw which is amazing start
from Brandon Jacobsen being one of the
youngest and lowest rated players in
Group B that would put him at two out of
three points and he would be on pace for
a GM norm given that most players in his
section are grandmasters six points for
Brandon Jacobsen will get him a
grandmaster norm and he just got the
International Master title officially
awarded to him at the fee des congrès in
Batumi several weeks ago or more recent
than that actually so yeah great
tournament for him to start out I wonder
I wonder if Group B will be all draws
today oh no maybe not in Chris you
versus Sergey Azeroth in Group E let's
take a look at that game his back did
have some pressure and I want to go back
to where we left off because it seems
like Chris you found this idea of rook
f3
a nice attempt to neutralize Locke's
active
and fight for control over the second
drink we CH 5 played H 5 is a very
typical move that you'll see in a lot of
these work endings especially to try and
undermine this very nice pawn chain box
sometimes has intention of putting the
King on f5 and restricting light from
advancing with pawn g4 and maybe even
someday playing upon H for himself
- perhaps induce some weaknesses so h5
is a very classical positional move now
we do see rook B to d3 prop centralizing
the rook now we see a 5 so as Aarav as
crops playing on both sides of the board
sometimes in order to win positions like
this you do need to utilize some
advantages on both the king side and the
Queen side and we see that blacks idea
is simply to play before and create a
passed pawn so Christopher responded
with rook to d5 securing the pawns and
black defends with rook to be to not
only defending b5 but having the very
nasty threat of either rook to c2 or
even rook c1 invading with the other
rook
so that prompted Christopher to play
rook to f2 and now it is as Arabs move
and after rook moves to f2 the sleeves
of third-ranked open for the black rook
I wouldn't be surprised here if we see a
move like rook to b3 and these pawns on
the 3rd rank see all of the pawns on the
3rd rank for whites seem quite
vulnerable and okay though the black
rook is somewhat tied down to defending
b5 but black but could potentially
double up on the 3rd rank with a move
coming like rook c2 c3 and I would not
be too happy if I were white in this
position
seems like Vox pressure is increasing
and I really like the way a Tsar was
playing given that he's uh he's been
poking around maneuvering his rooks and
it seems like now he's he's just finally
increasing the pressure to a point where
he might be very soon winning upon
in Group A the oldest player in the
field alexei gribov has progressed his
two versus one pawn situation on the on
the a and b files the pawns have been
traded and now there is a past a pawn
and he looks pretty good against erik
hansen now looks like a great position
there's still work to be done given that
hansen does have the blockade on a seven
but really have to admire the setup by
by white in this position this night is
very still beautifully placed on d5 and
now it's a matter of trying to advance
this a pawn even further and perhaps
trying to remove the bishop from a seven
could imagine that white is probably
pondering ideas of rookie three followed
by rook to b7 with an attempt to remove
the bishop and I'm not sure how black
would respond to this given that the
rook can't move back to e7 the knight is
just so effective on d5 now this was not
played instead ray of did capture on g5
first h h g5 and f take g5 was played
and now white has to pass pawns actually
pawn on e4 maybe not the strongest
passed pawn but it's a passed pawn
nonetheless and okay there's still this
idea of rook b3 rook d7 and I'm still
not sure how Hansen will deal with this
we see dre of played rook c3 very
similar idea threatening work to c7
seems like there's a lot of pressure and
we might get a situation where the
bishop may end up having to sacrifice
itself for the a pawn now I shouldn't
know here that if that could somehow
sacrifice the bishop for all of whites
remaining pawns we could see something
very similar to ashwin game where the
rook and Knights versus rook that would
be a dream scenario for Hansen but I
don't think he'll be able to achieve
that because it's very hard to remove
this very well defended pawn on e4 so I
do like Trey's chances especially
because they've made time control too so
there is time to perhaps figure out the
best end game technique for whites
I think we're caught up on all the games
right now we might glance at Linderman
Robson in just a bit but there are a lot
of big upcoming events here at the st.
Louis chess club that we will be
broadcasting to you and I'd like to tell
you about our upcoming schedule first of
all this is the fault chess classic but
you're not gonna have to wait until
winter proper for the winter chess
classic because it's coming to you
nearly right after this event 2:10
player round robins a 2500 level field a
2600 level field it's going to be great
$36,000 total prize fun on the line and
all begins on November 5 at u.s. chess
champs calm the roster will be released
and available shortly after this event
after that event we have uh norm
tournament it's the 2018 st. Louis
Invitational similar format I believe
the time control is a little bit
different but it'll still be to ten
player round-robin fields some players
will be going for their grandmaster
norms others will be going for their
international master norms and well even
if no one norms we're gonna have some
winners so that'll be a lot of fun also
at u.s. chess champs calm starting
November 16 and you'll note that it is
the season of a jam-packed schedule
because some of these events overlap
that day those days during the
invitational we will be having today in
chess and for very good reason because
in London the World Chess Championship
is on the line in a 12 game match Magnus
Carlsen defends against Fabiano Cara
Juana is the first American to go for
the lineal World Chess Championship
since Bobby Fischer in 1972 and each day
that there is a game in the match we
will have abbreviated coverage the match
goes from November 9th until the 28th
and I think it could go past that if
they have a playoff Eric so that'll be a
lot of fun you'll be able to watch that
on our youtube channel for more
information on that st. Louis chess club
org but that's not all today and chess
will be covering because also
besides the match championship will be
having the Women's World Chess
Championship and if you're thinking I
thought there was a match earlier this
year
you're right and there's a tournament
again this is the first year there will
be two Women's World Chess Championships
since 1937 okay in 81 years but this
will be a 64 player knockout similar to
the World Cup and juin June will be
defending her title with no special
privileges she'll be seeded into that 64
player knockout brutal stuff and it's
certain to be very exciting chess that
goes that starts on November 2 but we
will be recapping that starting on
November 9 when we're talking about the
World Chess Championships the Women's
World Championship is in Russia in
hunting Muncey's actually and then after
that well not yet the year continues
because it's the London chess classic to
be specific the Grantchester finals at
the London chess classic once again in
London from December 11th to the 17th we
know the top four players in the grand
chest or they will be competing in a
miniature knockout and yes that includes
Fabiano Cara wanna who may be the world
champion just sticking around and London
a little bit longer where it's gonna be
a mix of classical rapid and blitz games
all rated by the universal rate it's a
rating system 300 thousand dollar prize
fund on the line and the winner will be
the ultimate winner of the fourth annual
grand chess tour and for more
information on that grand chest or that
work
Oh Eric it's a lot of chess to look
forward to and that's just 2018 man we
can't wait for now you looking at 2019
yes that's just what like a month and a
half of events that if you're a chess
fan and even if you're not in the area
of st. Louis or London I mean there's
gonna be some spectacular shows to watch
online so really a golden age of chess
to watch so many different broadcasts
and I'm gonna be looking forward to that
myself
yeah live in the now this is the glory
days okay so we only have a few minutes
left in this show
we have five games remaining and I'm
seeing a whole lot of white in the meter
for DRAM versus Hanson did you want to
look at Lenderman versus Robson last
time I think it's been a little bit
since we've seen it yeah let's check it
out because a lot has come off the board
since we last saw this game and if we
count the pawns it's three on two
both Brookstone on the board Lenderman
clearly playing for a win in this
position the rooks are beautifully
coordinated on the seventh rank and
seems like black is a bit more passive
very passive rook on g8 and rook on b2 a
bit more active but especially in any
games where there's two rooks on the
this board for each player you really
want to make sure that your looks are
are coordinated are kind of speaking
with each other working towards some
common goal and in this case it seems
like the the goal for white is just
start advancing this past B pawn it is
an outside past pawn and Rey is going to
be on the defensive for the rest of this
game now it is a question of whether
Lenderman King actually converts once
this poly gets to b6 it gets a bit
awkward for white how to advanced it
further
given that the rook on b2 is putting
constant pressure along the B file so
I'm imagining some plan for white of
eventually putting the rook on e6
defending b6 and then shifting the other
over to allow the b-pawn to advance but
whenever this rook on b7 remove its
removes itself this could allow some
idea of rook to b8 so we will have to
keep an eye on this I'm expecting this
game to go at least another half hour to
hour if not longer given both players
still have a lot of time on their clock
in addition to the 30-second increments
this could be one of the longest games
of the rounds okay we have time for a
last glance which game do you want it to
be Eric I'm Dre of Hanson is is looking
like it maybe there's some more play
here but yeah it looks like drea totally
has it
that a pond let's take a last glance at
the handsome game I know the the twitch
chats as always rooting for the chess
brah at least in most cases and we can
see the the chests providing for his
life in this game after rook c6 check
let's actually go back after rook c3 we
saw g4 check King f4 and Bishop to b8
anticipating this idea of rook to be
rook to c7 to enable the pawn to advance
so this prompted drea to play rook c6
check and after rook e6
this is a counter check did Dre of
missus I didn't see this at first but
this is a discovered attack where this
bishop on b8 was aligned with the king
and rook e6 not only blocks a check of
the black king but unleashes a bishop
and now how does white deal with this if
you block the check on 5:25 yeah rook
takes you six nights are tricky 97 is a
fork and this would be winning for life
given after Knight takes c6 there would
be the unstoppable threat of a7
that's a good point but if he 5 is
played maybe I should take e5 with check
the White King would have to move we
could imagine that this room probably
has to take on c6 and then still Knight
d7 the King would move Knight take on c6
and this would be would be waiting for
white so maybe Dre of did not blunder
but maybe he saw this all ahead of time
but he is thinking in this position
which is perhaps a bit surprising
because what else can he play other than
B 5 if we go back to the current
position I mean maybe he's thinking of
rook c7 was some idea that after Bishop
takes he 7 they take c7 again this pawn
is about to score a touchdown and the
rook is in no good position
you stop it so perhaps there's still a
decision here but he does have enough
time on his clock I do like e5 I think
e5 should lead to a relatively simple
conversion maybe black would be best off
playing King f7 then okay keep rook take
you six even rook c8 ideas as well well
let's say rook take you six King take e6
perhaps there's still some hope for
Hanson in this position given that the
Knights and the pawn are under attack
and black would love to take the pawn
with check Dre have playing another move
that is actually much simpler that
neither of us really consider just
bringing the King back to e3 utilizing
the same idea of if rook takes c6 then
97 and yeah just should be winning for
whites so I do like King III and I still
very much like draya's chances to come
out on top but even in the endgame we
can see there's there's these tactical
lines where you can never let your guard
down you have to be constantly
calculating - to look at the concrete
variations as we wrap the show today
let's take a look at the results we have
coming in so far starting with Group A
now there are still three games in
progress which is unusual based on our
experience so far we've seen a draw
between cooze above and set 2 and of
course hammer has it's win over daro
after that beautiful hammer trap getting
that Queen and the rest of the three
games are pending and remember if you're
not watching on us chess champs calm
head on over there and you'll see these
games on the digital boards live and now
let's take a look at the B group results
today this is unusual
so far all draws but it may not end up
that way for the remaining games
well Eric any final thoughts on the
I mean I'm looking forward to staying
inside and then continuing to watch
these these games as they unfold I'll be
taking a look at at the continual
coverage of the online broadcast on I'll
probably look at the games on me chest
org especially with these later later
end games you can start using the table
bases to to determine which side is
winning but of course viewers can also
check out chests 24 calm and the main
website us chef's chance calm to follow
all the coverage whatever floats your
boat
and this broadcast was produced by the
world's greatest production B team
that's B for best Tami Hyde is the
streamer Isaac's France is the audio and
graphics man and our technical director
is Danny Machuca for international
master Eric Rosen my name is Ben Simon
we will see you tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
central but remember the game start at
1:00 so you can check them out early at
us chess champs calm until tomorrow we
say so long from the show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you